Hey Youtubers it's Charlie!
So arrow season four is back to confirm some
the things that we thought about what was
going on between the flashbacks present day
and we found out how they change the show
that they been teasing that they were to do
things very very differently this season in
terms of structure so you're going to do the
start by explaining the way they change the
show they fundamentally change the way the
show works okay will respond from the episode
starting up with the flashbacks what Marc
Guggenheim said is different about season
four is that what they used to do as they
would have characters from the flashbacks
that would transition to present-day they're
not gonna do that the flashbacks are to be
their own thing that is can it somatically
in form what's going on in present-day let
the darkness in that that's what it's all
about it seems like some of the characters
in present-day have already done that as per
that ending twist for the other part structurally
is that now it's much more fully integrated
with the flash like we talked about the high-speed
rail there metaphorically and literally connecting
those two cities in those characters so we
have grant Gustin at the end of the episode
with the flash 4 to 6 months from episode
one is a total gut punch ending but what is
doing is it's showing you the potential outcome
based on what ends up happening the season
for the road drama is finding out whether
or not they can change that or if that outcome
is a fixed point in time just to use Dr. Who
terms let's get in the top 10 WTF moments
will dig through it and we'll talk about all
the crazy strings including the hell Jordan
stuff or just a quick reminder I am doing
the reverse flash ring giveaway this week
and giving way to bring oriented and are is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on the
video starting with number 10 Oliver and Felicity
are living in Ivy Town that if you don't know
where this is this is where Ivy University
is if the home of the Ray Palmer Adam in the
comics is also much other firestorm stuff
that happens here just one of the many notable
DC comics cities like Metropolis or Gotham
city on the number nine speaking of ownership
Felicity is now rolling in cash as CEO of
Palmer tech although it seems kinda tenuous
at best right now because there's a board
is trying to challenge your control yes all
of the characters think that Ray Palmer is
dead but obviously we know about the item
we read the comics he really just shrunk down
at the end of season three I have no idea
how the show is going to surface him but at
some point he has to go alleges a tomorrow
so he has to figure out a way to regrow himself
expect at least one episode before the midseason
finale on arrow to address Ray Palmer to like
you affixed to get them back to normal size
the part of the fun of all of her and Felicity's
lives now just like that really awkward domesticity
that they have going on in and for those that
are wondering the tattoo that Oliver had removed
the to the Dragon that look just like shadows
tattoo from back on the island he's got like
wiping shadow from his life that I don't need
it anymore he got to remember shadow is just
a way for the show to say that he's got rid
of some of his demons he still does have that
Russian brought the tattoo that denotes his
rank is Capt. he's really high ranking officer
in the Russian mafia so so we might see a
little bit of that this year speed which number
eight Oliver is in Coast city in the flashbacks
release when they pick up trying to be the
hood of remember the progression from douche
bag college boy all over to green arrow is
to the end of this episode he started out
as Oliver turned into the hood first I was
his first persona that he became the arrow
and Odyssey now he's the green arrow so he
is the hood in these flashbacks as of right
now and we finally get a minimal back hopefully
will see her more the season but is on the
island so I've no idea yes you definitely
did see a Jordan jacket now that could be
hell Jordan I think that's what they want
you think they would put that in there fit
in what you think that but they can't really
do Green Lantern on arrow so I'm not expecting
to see a whole lot of Green Lantern stuck
at a time there Coast city they will put references
to Green Lantern things in their on the number
seven this five months away team arrow is
kind like team Diggle and Diggle has his new
costume the one that the is wearing was the
same one for me in the last season is just
like a modified version of Roy's costume who
is still trying to sell the idea of red arrow
limits so much that the is kind like this
Damien Wayne type character not just completely
going ancient completely ignoring the reality
of the situation is like I don't give a crap
about rowdy but she still really hates the
idea that they're calling her speedy the best
answer I have for that was the end of last
season where she kinda said hopefully it's
all over and he's a shut her down he looked
I'm pretty sure I Artie told everybody to
call you speedy so you think she's gonna be
turning into red arrow know she is the media
Dearden speedy her name is Thea Dearden Queen
what's going on here is that there hijacking
court industries weapons are just Damien Darhk
and hyper disarming up I feel like Ted Kord
is being put forward as the Steve Jobs of
the DC universe because he makes a really
awesome phone if you guys saw there was some
viral marketing for Batman view Superman was
like this Lex Luther thing where he made the
speech and we found out that he is Lex Luther
Junior but he also referenced Ted Kord and
that so Ted Kord is a very big figure in the
movies and on the TV show but I'm not expecting
to see my TV show anytime soon what is be
seeing a lot of people steal from him on the
number six meet your hive and Damien Darhk
so let's start with the big I Damien Darhk
big teen Titans villain from the comics but
he really only appeared in like and eight
issue miniseries so he's really not that big
of a character in the comics arrows, taken
some liberties he doesn't get too involved
with mysticism but in the episode Damien says
I want things to be ready for on my associates
get here obviously hive big villain organizations
can have other big villains that are part
of it that could also include Vandal Savage,
Vandal Savage of course not going to show
up on arrow till episode eight so that could
be the timeline for when he's trying to make
the city ready just to bookmarking that we
really don't have enough information to start
positing what's going on with Vandal Savage's
involvement in all this for the most part
just think of hive is like an elite version
of the league of assassins with more high
tech gear on the number five shocking twist
number one Quentyn Lance has been working
with hive this whole time when we don't if
it's been five months we don't know how long
we just know that his relationship with Damien
Darhk predates episode one to presumably at
some point black canary will probably find
out what her father's been up to and why he
did it it seems like what happened is Damien
Darhk rolled into town and just said look
there's no way you can fight me so you can
either work for me or I can kill you but you
let the darkness and the darkness changes
you if you really want to season three year
member that was actually a line of dialogue
that was uttered during the black canary story
arc it was all about Laurel letting the darkness
in and out Quentyn is the one that's letting
the darkness and I mean I was the victim of
the metaphor crosses all the characters in
different ways like Damien Darhk literally
lets the darkness and with those you know
those weird tattoos and runes on his arms
the other characters like Thea Diggle letting
the darkness and metaphorically like emotionally
when I saw this twist I got so excited this
is like the best possible thing for Paul Blackthorne
he's an amazing drama after he does great
genre stuff but his Quentyn Lance storyline
in season three just didn't do it for me like
he just didn't have a very exciting storyline
season for general is all about the nature
of family in what you do for family you know
is your family the people you're born to or
is it the family you choose for yourself but
on a number for all of her integral kind of
heal the family of team arrow so now their
team green arrow although it's much more anklet
Terry and if you remember they were kind of
running the city by committee the beginning
the episode that's kind of how team arrows
can function this year to the used to be all
over building a team around him now kinda
more of a shared responsibility kind of thing
so Diggle and Oliver will be sharing a lot
of leadership responsibility but is much as
Diggle was really upset about him he gets
that called action from Lila worth like to
get over it I forgiven Oliver you should too
don't be a bridge so as of that called action
that Oliver had in the episode where he hijacks
the emergency broadcast like I don't think
Diggle's completely forgiven him but they're
not can have like a lot of internal drama
but doubt that was kinda meant to cut that
off flexing like this is gonna be a thing
every single episode when I can be fighting
all the time so while the family problems
are to be having the season most of them are
going to be between blood family members select
the and Oliver to be having some problems
because she's gone super dark Quentyn and
Laurel to be having a lot of problems because
he is gone super dark on the number three
Oliver gets dumped back on the island don't
know a ton about the season for flashbacks
only that the big villain in the flashbacks
will be Berendt blitzkrieg I'm assuming that
a lot of it at least the first half of the
season will take place on the island but I
don't know these can be bouncing back and
forth between coast city and the island sometimes
the only way out is through so Oliver, working
through his darkness by going into the mouth
of Hell which is kind of twisting the metaphor
because Leanne you actually means purgatory
on the number two Felicity unveils Cisco's
latest creation the green arrow costume which
probably has all kinds a tech that will learn
about just one more way that they're tying
both shows together in a like I said that
the high-speed rail we had Barry Allen at
the end of the episode all kinds of stuff
tying the shows together the costume itself
looks pretty awesome I mean Annville the comic
con suite we've had a couple months to think
about it, it's a little bit weird but I'm
really just excited to see like what's underneath
the hood like what the Sioux can do we do
know right now that it does not offer him
any protection from Damien Darhk's abilities
and actually this Damien Darhk seen that he
has this fight scene is to let you know that
arrow as the show has activated final boss
form but Damien Darhk himself is not completely
on tillable he's not completely invincible
that's why Diggle is able to train him just
a little bit every time Oliver tries to fight
him he's pointing to get his ass handed to
him that they need to learn more about the
nature Damien Darhk's abilities before they
can fight them will send you some sort of
connection with this totem I'm wondering if
either he's going to turn into an actual demon
like a literal personification of darkness
or if team arrow is like smashed the I like
they have to do something to neutralize his
abilities a certain point but that seems like
it's so far off like you probably season finale
of the season is all about what happens when
you let the darkness in and presumably darkness
will just overtake Damien Darhk in a really
bad way I know everybody would love to see
the demon each again I don't think we never
seem on arrow though but now that Constantine
is no longer a show at least a have a chance
to finally on my number one WTF moment of
course it looks like a member of team arrow
has died six months in the future just plotting
this timeline that would put it at the end
of the season so it looks like their flashing
forward to like episode 23 I've heard it said
that the writers are still deciding who is
going to go in that grave like it could change
depending on which way the story goes the
season okay I don't know who was in the casket
grade tombstone etc. literally I don't they
don't write like every single episode before
they start shooting episode one but they only
have up to I think like the midseason finale
right now I have an idea for the one in that
great but that could change in the back half
of the season right now I think it could either
be Diggle it could be Quentyn or it could
be Felicity I think it's a little misleading
to assume that it's Felicity just because
that thinking right after that moment with
Oliver but think about what Oliver said when
he was talking to Barry there would've been
a time that I would've thought this had been
my fault bringing this darkness to the city
and that's taken from the scene that he had
with Quentyn I think it's more likely that
Quentyn is in the grave and he is just like
really upset about what happened to quite
like the dark path that he was set on this
is the big debate that can have this week
let me know in the comments who is in that
grave like why do you think that it is that
person the reason that I don't think that
is the is because they killed her lassies
and to be like them recycling the plot all
over again be like biologist dumper in the
Lazarus bid and if you were Felicity and Oliver
would probably be inconsolable like you try
just be like like a multi-pile of flesh and
in the same it just looks like he has great
regret it doesn't look like someone that he
was getting ready to get married to just died
but at this point remember the writers have
not decided who is in the grave so so whoever
you come up with you're not wrong like there
is no wrong answer this point I am to do a
Q&A for this to leave all your questions in
the comments on this and on my flash episode
one video that can oppose after my agent to
show video nicely to catch up on that because
I was in Austin up so this week to be sure
to subscribe to get everything is a couple
of the trailers like Jessica Jones is a sure
electrical alternative that on Friday summer
to get through agent to shield and arrow flash
stuff tomorrow is the other bequest than what
you guys answer for me to of the two premieres
arrow in the flash who you think had the better
episode one another both amazing personally
I think that arrow had the better episode
like just the way was constructed the narrative
the way they change the show even if you're
just talking about who had the most improved
episode like from season to season I think
arrow did a better job even though both arrow
and flash are amazing this week I'm so excited
about the season of arrow and flash so like
I said is a nation be like one big story stretched
out over three shows when you throw legend
tomorrow in there too so yes you do need to
watch arrow and flash each week to keep up
in case you haven't seen it you can click
here for my flash episode one video last night
and you can click here for 8 to 11 and is
video thank you so much watching everybody
a green arrow high-five and I'll see you guys
tomorrow